vamos ahora con el problema 112 en el
problema 112 nos piden determinar si acá
le gana a t y tenemos los siguientes
incisos de información en el 1 nos dicen
que cada porte es igual a 24 lo cual
claramente no nos va a decir nada acerca
de esta desigualdad porque esta es una
condición simétrica por ejemplo si
tenemos acá igual a 6 y te igual a 4
entonces casi le gana a t pero si
tenemos acá igual a 4 y 6 entonces acá
no le gana a t y en ambos casos el
producto es 24 entonces este inciso por
sí mismo no nos permite determinar si se
da esta desigualdad o no vamos a ver qué
dice el inciso 2 en el 2 nos dice que
acá cuadrada k cuadrada le gana a t
cuadrada va ahora hay que tener cuidado
aquí podemos sacar raíz en una
desigualdad sólo cuando tenemos cuando
tenemos que acá y te son positivos si
son negativos pueden pasar cosas raras
por ejemplo si acá es igual a menos 6
te es igual a menos 4 entonces tenemos
que acá es menor que ten pero acá al
cuadrado es 36 que le ganaste al
cuadrado porque eso es 16 vale pero pero
si si son positivos si tenemos que acá
es igual a 6 y te es igual a 4 entonces
cada al cuadrado 36 le gana a 16 y aquí
se preserva la desigualdad acá es mayor
que te cae es mayor que te y cada
cuadrado es mayor que te cuadrada vale
entonces este inciso por sí mismo
claramente no nos permite concluir si
acá le gana ateo no tenemos estos dos
casos pero incluso estos ejemplos son
ejemplos de que ni siquiera combinándolo
con el inciso 1 podemos determinar si la
desigualdad se da porque en estos
ejemplos que aporté sigue siendo 24 sí
que aporté es menos 6 x menos 4 que es
24 y aquí es 6 por 4 que es 24 entonces
ni siquiera juntando la información de
los dos incisos podemos responder y
entonces la respuesta es sí
vamos ahora el problema 113
113 este tiene una figura que ya
preparen que es esta de acá está de acá
deja te explico un poco la figura el
problema dice que esta región d es un
triángulo rectángulo es un triángulo
rectángulo con área 4 entonces tenemos
que el área de de de este triángulo
rectángulo es 4 déjame llamarle a este
lado ve pequeña a este lado c pequeña
entonces tenemos que un medio debe x c
es igual a 4 esto es lo mismo que decir
que b c es igual a 8 y que lo que nos
piden es determinar el lado de esta
región cuadrada
o sea nos dicen que es un cuadrado
cuadrado y si su lado se llama a
minúscula entonces lo que necesitamos
determinar es el valor de la minúscula
vale bueno los incisos de información
que nos dan son los siguientes en el
inciso 1 lo que nos dicen es que el área
de la región cuadrada b es de 9 entonces
el área
a área espérame tantito esta área debe
es igual a 9 muy bien si el área de be
es igual a 9 y es un cuadrado eso quiere
decir que cada uno de sus lados es raíz
del 9 o sea 3 entonces esta información
la del inciso 1 nos permite concluir que
b es igual a 3 y conociendo el valor de
b podemos determinar el valor de c
porque sabemos que porsche es igual a 8
sale o sea poniendo ve pequeña igual a 3
aquí tenemos que 13 es igual a 8 y
dividiendo entre 3 de ambos lados que es
igual a 8 tercios
entonces la información del inciso 1 nos
permite conocer este lado nos permite
conocer este lado y como tenemos un
triángulo rectángulo podemos aplicar el
teorema de pitágoras para conocer este
lado simplemente al cuadrado es igual a
b al cuadrado más sea al cuadrado y esto
de aquí es igual a 8 al cuadrado más 8
tercios
al cuadrado y de aquí podríamos
determinar el valor de a pero eso no nos
importa únicamente nos interesa saber si
se puede o no entonces el inciso 1 si es
suficiente para determinar el valor de a
vamos a ver qué ocurre con el inciso 2
en el inciso 2 nos dicen que el área
el área del cuadrado ce es igual a 64
novenos es igual a 64 novenos entonces
es básicamente lo mismo verdad si el
área de 64 novenos se minúscula es la
raíz cuadrada de esto que sería 8
tercios este mismo valor que nos quedó
por acá a partir de que se es igual a 8
tercios y el área de d es 4 podemos
obtener el valor de b poniendo que b por
8 tercios es igual a 8
de modo que b es igual a 3
es igual a 3 y a partir de aquí podemos
continuar exactamente como lo hicimos
acá vale otra vez no vamos a determinar
el valor porque en el examen de james
sería una pérdida de tiempo únicamente
nos interesa saber si la información que
nos dan es suficiente o no y en este
caso cualquiera de los incisos ayudó a
responder la pregunta y por lo tanto la
respuesta sería de de vale ok pasemos
ahora al problema 114 se lo voy a hacer
en color rosa problema 114 y voy a bajar
un poco para tener más espacio problema
114 dice que x se va a elegir
aleatoriamente de un conjunto t entonces
x d
un conjunto
junto
de un conjunto de muy bien y lo que nos
preguntan es la probabilidad de que un
cuarto de x menos 5 sea menor o igual
que 0 queremos la probabilidad de que un
que 0 esto está un poco difícil de
pensar déjame vea cómo darle un poco
pedir esto es lo mismo que pedir que un
cuarto de x sea menor o igual que 5
sumando 5 de ambos lados ahora podemos
pasar el 4 multiplicando porque es
positivo y no cambia la desigualdad
entonces nos quedaría x menor o igual
que 20 y entonces pues básicamente nos
estamos preguntando por la probabilidad
de que x sea menor o igual que 20 esto
es más fácil de pensar verdad bueno
vamos a ver qué nos dicen que nos dicen
los incisos de información en el 1 nos
dice que t
este es un conjunto es un conjunto
junto de ocho enteros enteros esto es
muy poquita información o sea nos dice
cuántos elementos tiene t pero no nos
dice por dónde están a lo mejor todos
estos son mayores que 20 y entonces la
probabilidad sería 0 o todos estos dt
son menores que 20 y la probabilidad
sería 1 entonces pues realmente esto no
nos da mucha información sale
vamos a ver qué dice el inciso 2 en el 2
dice que te está contenido en el
conjunto de enteros de 1 a 25 entonces
te está
contenido
contenido en este conjunto este conjunto
de japón la llave así bonita 1 2 3
etcétera 24 25 bueno eso ya habla un
poquito más acerca del tamaño de las
posibles x pero me parece que todavía no
dice gran cosa porque a lo mejor te es
un conjunto que está muy acumulado en
los números grandes o buenos o muy
acumulado en los números chiquitos vaya
incluso nada más con dos pues ni
siquiera sabemos cuántos elementos tiene
te vale entonces ha sido solito no
funciona pero aunque supiéramos cuántos
elementos tiene por ejemplo si también
supiéramos el inciso 1 que son 8 pues
esos 8 podrían ir del 1 al 8 y entonces
la probabilidad sería 1 porque todos
esos son menores iguales que 20 pero a
lo mejor no sé a lo mejor los 8 son los
de hasta el final no sé de bueno no sé
cuántos son pero los 8 últimos y la
probabilidad ya no sería 1 entonces ni
siquiera juntando la información de
estos dos podemos determinar la
probabilidad
x sea menor o igual que 20 y así la
respuesta sería
muy bien vamos al 115 en el problema 115
nos dicen lo siguiente nos dicen que la
edad de sara es exactamente el doble de
la edad débil entonces la edad de sara
la edad ve
este es a ese no quiere quedar bonita la
edad de sara es exactamente el doble de
la edad débil ok y lo que quieren que
determinemos lo que quieren que
determinemos es la edad de sara muy bien
vamos a ver qué información nos dan en
el inciso 1 nos dice que nos dicen que
hace 4 años la edad de sara era
exactamente tres veces la edad débil ok
entonces hace cuatro años s -4 realidad
de sara hace cuatro años
era exactamente tres veces la edad débil
pero alperovich tenía hace cuatro años
4 - cuatro años vale entonces esta
información será suficiente para
determinar el valor de ese yo digo que
si mira aquí básicamente nos están
diciendo que ese menos 4 es igual a 3 b
menos 12 menos 12 y de aquí pues podemos
determinar el valor de s simplemente
tendríamos que sustituir pues b con el
valor de s que tiene aquí aquí tenemos
que es igual a s entre 2 lo voy a hacer
para que me creas entonces aquí podemos
sumar 4 de ambos lados nos queda que ese
es igual a 3 veces ves es entre 2
entonces sería tres veces ese entre 2 y
aquí sumamos 4 éste se hace menos 8 ok
entonces tenemos aquí y aquí tres medios
de s podemos sumar ocho de ambos lados
me queda 8 es igual a restamos s de
ambos lados aquí nos queda ese medios
haciendo rápido nada más para que veas
que se puede pero recuerda que en la
prueba de game at no hay que detenerse
en estas cosas y aquí multiplicando por
2 nos queda que es igual a 16 vale
entonces la información del inciso 1 nos
permite determinar la edad de sara
vamos a ver qué dice el inciso 2 en el
inciso 2 lo que nos dicen es que dentro
de ocho años la edad de sara será 1.5
veces la edad débil es algo muy similar
verdad dentro de ocho años ahora tendrá
s más ocho años y nos dicen que eso será
exactamente 1.5 veces 1.5 veces la edad
débil o sea de más 8
8 y otra vez 1 lo que hace es tomar este
valor debe sustituirlo aquí obtener una
ecuación lineal en ese y despejar la
entonces en realidad bueno esto no lo
tuve que hacer y aquí pues puedo hacer
algo muy similar que tampoco tengo que
hacer
lo que sí nos interesa es que juntando
la información de cualquiera de los
incisos con lo que tenemos aquí arriba
podemos determinar la edad de sara vale
entonces la respuesta sería de
cualquiera de los incisos nos permite
responder la pregunta vamos a seguir en
el próximo vídeo nos vemos hasta
entonces